technology is scary if black mirror has
taught us anything it shows us how
technology can be easily manipulated and
how scary it really can be
today's video we're going to be going
into night city and explain some creepy
and scary things of this city
two bits of information though that will
be relevant throughout the rest of the
video this doesn't necessarily mean
everything in this video is only
available in night city and nowhere else
within the us we are just discussing
things that are present in night city
and possibly in other places and two
this video is made before the release of
cyberpunk 2077 so i'm using the
information we have gathered from cd
projekt red themselves like the world of
cyberpunk 2077 lore book to help find
confirmed information so expect a sequel
to the series when the game releases and
we get a lot more information on night
city by actually playing it but to start
the video i do have one question
do you like entertainment everyone loves
it right
it keeps people busy and well
entertained
enter brain dance it's the most powerful
form of entertainment in night city
it's a digital recording of a person's
experiences streamed right into their
brain
via a special augment it's like the
superior version of virtual reality
users of this technology can find videos
and experience
everything and the recorder of the media
felt emotions
sensations thoughts and memories and you
are living through what that person went
through
almost as if you were that person within
the given situation
there are some interesting types though
brain dance there's the ones for arcade
goers patients who are mentally ill and
need assistance
people who want to experience the club
life and people who want to engage in
intercourse
but there are also two other types black
and penitentiary black brain dance is
raw unfiltered footage of criminal
activity it's often extremely violent
and psychotic
since you are feeling every single
emotion and sense you feel like you are
the killer there is little to no editing
quality so it's just
raw thoughts of criminals there are
little barriers required to view these
types of videos so experiencing this
content is very dangerous as can cause
the users to suffer significant and
sometimes permanent psychological damage
even though there are warnings people
still view these when they want and some
criminal organizations have made revenue
and names for themselves but then
braindance for this style of content
where black is more
for the willing criminal to entertain
the masses penitentiary is for the
unwilling criminal this one has its ups
and downs made back in the early 2000s
these are for convicts who require
rehabilitation
it's a form of psychological
conditioning that breaks down the
wearer's will
and practically conforms them to
cooperate and comply it replaced the
crime they were found guilty for which
is usually a felony and placed them in
the role of the victim so if a criminal
tortured someone and then shot them
since braindance records all emotion and
senses you would feel like the victim
being tortured and then shot to death
the prisoners watching don't actually
die but they feel like they have
and this plays constantly so they're
getting the feeling of dying over and
over again this leads to them having a
huge dislike of violence and can lead
them to developing anti-social behaviors
and anxiety disorders
so it does what it's supposed to do to
make the criminal not commit more crimes
via rehabilitation but at what cost
let me know what you think about this
one but there could still be problems
even with the regular viewing of brain
dance such as bd
did or brain dance dissociative identity
disorder
which is as it sounds it's did but
people think they're the
individual being portrayed within the
brain dance they're watching and while
it's only been recorded a few times
some people have been so involved within
the person they've been viewing via
brain dance they've even attempted
murderers on that person out of jealousy
the other typical things that can happen
consist of health problems due to
inactivity poor nutrition and mental
isolation if you use it for too long
it's unclear how expensive brain dance
is but it seems people of all social
classes can purchase and experience
brain dance
speaking of social class in business
we're at number two
in night city even in the cyberpunk
universe megacorporations like arasaka
and militech as an example
have immense amounts of power
economically and politically
they have more power than some
governments and make their own cultures
laws and social systems this is why the
fourth corporate wars almost wiped out
the entire country which you can learn
about up here as we explain that in
detail
in the universe of cyberpunk it's either
you are with the megacorporations or
alone and if you're alone you're either
a freelancer a struggling entrepreneur
or
unemployed there's no in between because
they hold so much power you are more
expendable than ever
you screw up once are ineffective or act
out you're fired if you betray the
company you could be killed within
corporations and their workers there's a
separate personal hierarchy
there are the dominated the lowest
possible these are your cleaners drivers
and security guards they receive basic
medical care and housing it's not great
but it's better than nothing
above them is the intermediate the
middle class of the corporate workers
they are the hardest working for a
little effort as they work 16 hour days
stim pills are constantly used to regain
energy and sleeping pills are used for
sleeping it's constantly about work and
only work in hopes of a promotion this
promotion could mean a small condo or
apartment in one of the corporate
buildings
their own work car increase the salary
and from time to time
actual fresh food even though they are
higher it's getting worse
and the prime league as it's called
people are constantly wanting promotions
and will do anything for an increase to
what they currently have
you have to be one step ahead of every
single co-worker you work with in order
to get farther
people at this level will do anything
they can to get a promotion hire
netrunners to find dirty data
bribe cops buy info from fixers anything
to get ahead
it's a high risk high reward style full
of competition
and constant stress even if you can get
this high and surpass it you are now
part of the small portion of people the
dominating
full of board members ceos corporate
owners and blue bloods while it sounds
like the top is safe
and comfortable there is tons of eager
younglings and lower positions
wanting that spot from you even though
you are constantly hurting others for
your gain in this environment
nothing is as important as your job you
can't be part of the prime league in
your corporation
if there is no corporation so workers in
an attempt to weaken rival businesses
and hopefully catch the eyes of a board
member
will do anything they can against these
other businesses lie
bribe blackmail and kidnapping to name a
few sometimes the corporations even do
it themselves they just hire assassins
or private military to abduct people and
sabotage buildings
people at the top only got there through
backstabbing scheming and alliances the
phrase nice guys finish
last is very relevant to the business
world of night city of course the last
position left within the business world
that's kind of on its own is celebrities
they bring the music the talent and the
trends to the world the group us cracks
is a product of this while they sing and
perform all the time they're constantly
setting standards for the fashion
industry
thus making fashion companies more money
and in turn them more money managers
will find people like us cracks
individuals with clear talent and help
them unpack it and produce
revenue from it they get to live this
rich relaxing life full of mansions
yachts
limos and private jets but if there's
even a slight dip in their performance
or revenue they can be replaced by
others with similar talents
you are just as expendable as the
dominated working class with the slight
high of living a lavish life for as long
as the industry sees fit and this was
just the social
hierarchy for the corporations the
reason this was brought up first is that
usually the middle class
non-corporation citizens are the lower
class like the dominated
in the corporate world people who are
middle class but don't like mega
corporations tend to have their own
businesses garages coffee shops studios
and small clinics
they're just trying to get by without
selling their body or souls to ceos
because of this decision though they
usually live in poorer districts with
less security
and more crime and they have no medical
or social insurance since the
corporations will provide this to all
workers
so it's all out of their own pocket and
there's even a new version of this
called the new middle class these people
are
still middle class but are super close
to riding the line of poverty and
they're mostly uneducated and unemployed
and just barely getting by enough to
save up some money by running illegal
businesses
and now we've come to the bottom of the
bottom thanks to society's changes in
the last 50 years and megacorporations
the expression the rich get richer and
the poor get poorer couldn't be more
relevant today these people are
unemployed
homeless some even with addictions to
drugs or brain dance
high mortality rates are prevalent among
the social class thanks to disease
gang activity and drug overdose
corporations and security officials have
actually tried to solve this issue by
either placing these people
in camps or executing vast groups of
them as sad as it is though it's cheaper
to ignore these people rather than find
solutions to their problems
violence is of course at an all-time
high thanks to this as people don't want
to struggle to survive or die so people
in the lower class will rob and steal
from others which leads to number three
pre-emptive self-defense people carrying
weapons in night city is out of the
question
in fact it's more accessible than ever
the worst of the worst weapons can be
bought at vending machines
while bad though at least it's a weapon
mid-level weapons can be found in
supermarkets and convenience stores
these are mostly for the beginners that
want their first gun but want something
that will last
unlike the former the more experienced
tend to go to the devoted gun stores for
their armaments the common citizen
really does only get this far though as
heavy class weapons are for mega
corporations only this doesn't mean that
you can't get some for yourself it's
just not legal fixers can provide
people who want the top line of weapons
such as cutting edge prototypes
as long as they have the cash if you
aren't a fan of carrying your weapons
around or prefer to be more covert about
your arsenal then consider buying an
offensive augment like swords or micro
rockets stored within your arms
it's obvious from the examples that
weapons are everywhere it's probably
harder to find someone without weapons
than with one
in comes pre-emptive self-defense this
principle is used throughout the u.s in
an attempt by the government to extend
the second amendment rights and says if
an individual is provoked they are
always authorized to use deadly force to
prevent the infliction of significant
bodily harm or death each state while
following this principle is a little bit
different than the next as it's unclear
exactly what provoked means as some
states are pretty lenient about this as
most people have offensive augments or
weapons and people could see that as
suspicious or threatening which gives
them the full right to shoot it's a very
vague principle that needs to be more
specific as this could kill innocents
imagine somebody robs the store
the store owner and robber are both
carrying weapons the store owner could
kill the robber since that owner would
be provoked and fearing for their life
but if the owner whips out a gun then
the robber is fearing for his life
so does he have the right to shoot as
well or does he get in trouble still
because he instigated it
like i said this is super vague and not
detailed enough remember in the
beginning when i said black mirror
taught us the dangers of technology i
want to reinforce that with net running
in its most basic form it's the internet
used by people who have a modem and want
to use the internet or the net as it's
called in cyberbunk and just like the
internet people can use it
on a tablet or a mouse and keyboard to
surf the web but some people want a more
3d experience
using a cyber modem this is called
netrunning and the people that use this
are considered netrunners the positives
of netrunning is that you can customize
an avatar to roam around within the
digital world
and it allows data transfers to be more
direct and faster as you could
physically plug yourself into the data
but the neck got ruined thanks to the
supposed death of reish bartmoss the
most talented netrunner who said when i
die
so will the net and upon his death he
released his roving autonomous bartmoss
interface drones or rabbids for short
they went into the net and sent data
everywhere they ended up taking files
from data fortresses which is the net
representation of a computer
and they swapped it with other data
fortresses and collapsed everything
thanks to this it is extremely crippled
and while it is still slowly healing
in ways to prevent this from happening
again netwatch the people that watch
over the net have walled off corporate
files and are now behind what's called
the black wall
where only a few runners have gone in
2077 the net is still used and is
extremely fractured mostly containing
separated local hubs these hubs are city
national and state hubs with a mix of
public and private domains
the old map past the black wall is now
the deep net or the deep web in real
life
it's confirmed to have old databases and
loose files and that's all the info that
really is on it as many
don't go past the wall people could pay
others to get info for them whether it's
legal or not and it was even used within
the fourth corporate war
there are even augments dedicated to
netrunning low level upgrades like a
personal link that can help you
physically plug into chosen ports
up to tier 5 upgrades which allows the
user to be completely aware of their
surroundings
remotely connect to cyberspace within
the field and directly attack other
runners and counter any unauthorized
interference
while also including some tier 4 systems
like blood cooling
life support and cryostasis although the
previous stuff we just mentioned in tier
5
is only available to the netwatch
employees but
why would they need to kill people
within the cyberspace that's mostly due
to the voodoo boys the voodoo boys while
not threatening in the streets of night
city are extremely threatening in the
cyberspace
roughly 10 gangs are detailed within the
official lore book and
all with threats detailing low medium
and high threat levels
the voodoo boys are the only ones in the
book at the fourth tier
extreme in real life our data is king
he who owns the most data owns the most
power
imagine given the past stuff we just
talked about how important a citizen of
night city's data is
which is why i think they're the most
dangerous game i personally think
they're the most dangerous gang in night
city but i'd love to hear your
reasonings if you disagree with me
while not having the most members
compared to other gangs they're
originally from pacifica with unmatched
skills and netrunning and have a taste
for the voodoo flavor
the group consists of those only with
haitian blood and are extremely
distrustful to outsiders the reason
being because of haiti being abandoned
in 2062 due to natural disasters
the voodoo boys are like the
self-appointed guardians of the refugees
of haiti who constantly want to find all
the secrets of the old net pass the
black wall
they primarily gain revenue from hacking
data banks and accounts with various
corporations in search of top secret
data to exploit use or blackmail with
they can also get hired as mercenary
netrunners by private contractors who
are interested in hit and run netrunning
or want info on the old net it's also
speculated that they steal virtual
currency and carry out information
brokering and that's why i think they're
the most dangerous gang in night city
but once again i want to reiterate this
is totally an opinion on this last one
so i want to hear what you think down in
the comments down below but that's gonna
be the end
for today as always thank you guys for
joining me on the journey through this
video and let me know what you think
about the content
video ideas are always accepted in the
comments down below so don't hesitate to
let me know what you want to see
take care guys and i'll see you in the
next cyberpunk video goodbye
[Music]
you